i'm sure i got some people watching this
video as a fan of final fantasy tactics
ogre battle
advance wars those older games that was
made around the 90s that a lot of people
really gravitate towards they have a lot
of excitement for if you like those
games i think i got a game for you it's
called symphony of war it's made by
dancing dragon games and published by
freedom games want to shout out them for
sending me the review code and this is
my review on symphony of war for steam
let's get on with it
[Music]
what's going on you guys lord act here
coming at you for another review you
guys know that i'm a huge fan of
turn-based games i'm a really big fan of
jrpgs in general and i do got a game
that kind of mixtures those two together
now for those of you that play the old
tactics ogre games i think a lot of
people when it comes to this type of
gameplay that great style gameplay we're
always looking for new fixes on this
type of gameplay because it's a very
unique thing that i don't think a lot of
people take advantage of so when we was
at pax this year there was a game in
particular that lord attic wanted to get
his hands on it was called sympathy of
war it's pretty much a turn based game
that's kind of like squad based you know
how when you're looking at it think of
like fire emblem you know game play such
as that now there is a few things i want
to go over real quick before we get into
this now now we all love tactics ogre
and i think that this game kind of
inspires by tactics ogre and final
fantasy tactics now especially when it
comes to the soundtrack i feel like the
soundtrack is very heavenly final
fantasy tactics like and i really
enjoyed that i feel like you know we got
a good thing of both worlds now as far
as the story goes let's go ahead and
start with that now i honestly feel like
the story of this game is very good like
it's and i can't really begin to
describe to you how good this game is in
terms of story like now you guys know
how i don't really go into too much of a
detail but here's pretty much what it is
like think of game of thrones think of
you know giant wars going on you're in
the middle of all this chaos and there's
betrayals going on there's a lot of plot
twists the story of this game i would
say if i would have put like a number on
it would be like maybe like i would say
a solid eight to nine out of ten i felt
very interested in what's going to
happen next in this story they had a lot
of good side characters a lot of good
side quests that happened in this game i
will say that the side quest was a
little bit less appealing in this game
than i would have liked and what i mean
appealing is there wasn't a lot of it
now there was a good amount there was
about one chapter where it was pretty
much like look you can do the main story
you can do all these side quests i would
really prefer that they went and let you
have a lot more aspects in terms of side
content where you can do something in
almost every chapter and maybe a little
bit of cause and effect when it comes to
the story for the most part you're gonna
play the game exactly how the story is
written there's not really any kind of
choice and that's not really anything
like bad against the game i know a lot
of you probably playing fire emblem
stuff you know games that's similar to
this type of game play and there's a lot
of choice diameters that go on in those
type of games so if you're really
expecting that in this game it's not
really present in this game all you can
expect when it comes to story is they
give you a solid foundation solid side
characters solid villains in the game
and you're going throughout the game
learning more and more about the lore of
this country that is have all of this
beef there's so much beef in this game
it's unreal it's like i said there's a
bunch of betrayals and a lot of story
aspects in general now as far as the
performance i do have a pretty beefy pc
and i don't think this game is going to
take much to run on pc and i had very
few actual like game breaking bugs there
were occasional stuff that i had like
reset and stuff like that but it wasn't
enough to make me feel like it impacted
my experience in this game the music in
this is actually one of the highlights
of it now there's a lot of different
emotional ties going on here and it's
like i said earlier in the video i felt
very final fantasy tactics soundtracks
on this now is it one for one no of
course not but you know go ahead and
look at that i'm not gonna put it on the
the video itself because i don't know
how it goes with copyright and stuff
like that but if you put some of these
soundtracks next to like an old final
fantasy tactic soundtrack they sound a
lot similar especially some of the shock
factor music in this game you know in
general if you have anything being
compared to final fantasy tactics
soundtrack you know it's definitely a
good start and i think that the
soundtrack of this game is a very solid
thing now i'm not saying every song on
here sounds like tactics but there are a
couple that kind of dude now let's get
into the gameplay you guys know what
this type of game this ogre battle final
fantasy tactics red emblem you know a
lot of the times the game plays the make
it or break it stuff and what i will say
is a lot of these type of games don't
really go away from that grid space but
there are some unique things in here i
feel like they took some of that final
fantasy tactics and ogre battle and they
kind of mixed it with the red emblem
fire emblem it so look this is how it
pretty much goes now typically when you
play these type of games how they
normally goes you have a grid space
gameplay with unique units individual
units that you build up to fight with
everyone that kind of resembles an
actual squad now the way sympathy of war
works is actually you have individual
units that you build a squad with them
that they fight together as an army now
i know that kind of sounds weird i'm
going to put in the background where you
can see a little bit more on what i'm
saying
every unit has a select amount of people
that they can have on their team and you
can eventually level up the amount of
people that he can have on the team now
it is a three by three so you can only
have a max of nine people on the field i
know nine doesn't sound like a lot for
one squad but after you start
accumulating a lot of people that is a
lot that you won't really get to i think
only had one squad in this entire game
that actually had nine units in the
squad because most of these units that
you want to you want symmetry you want
certain abilities work better with other
abilities certain classes are weakness
or strengths against other classes and
you want to make sure you have a good
synergy on the battlefield you want to
have a squad that does archery you want
to have a squad that does cavalry you
want to have a squad that does spears so
they can take on the cavalry like it has
a huge in-depth game play on this game
and the longer you play the more you
unlock these more advanced classes of
these respected units and i really enjoy
that especially when you start getting
further in the game and they start
showing you dragons yes i said it
dragons you know and what's cool about
the dragons portion is you can actually
level them up from you know a small
dragon to a medium-sized dragon to a
full-blown dragon and if you really
really invest into that unit you can
eventually have people riding on the
dragons and that's probably one of the
most strongest units in the game now
what is cool about this is they have
artifacts now an artifact is pretty much
these items that you can get throughout
the game through neither drops or
there's actually a store in here where
you can buy units and items and that's
pretty much with all the money you can
pretty much what you want to do is buy
all the items in the game and then get
the units that you would actually want
to have so when you get these artifacts
it will either raise strength raise
magic but there's always usually a
negative that goes with it so if you
raise your magic by some it's going to
lower your strength by some and what's
cool is that artifacts themselves
go off the cap level of how many people
you can have in the unit now remember i
was saying that you can eventually level
up these leaders to have more people in
your actual barracks or well you know
your unit in general so let's say that
you know you already have an established
unit that you don't want to put any more
people in you know it does exactly what
it needs to do so what you can do is you
can go into the artifacts and you can
really have more in-depth abilities and
have a lot more customization to that
unit that does exactly what you want it
to do for instance if you really like
archers on here and you decided to go
out there and get a leader that gives
special perks to an archer and you can't
do that leaders on here certain of them
have special unique abilities that if
they're a leader their entire unit gets
and that gives you even more
customization on top of the artifacts on
top of the class system that they have
on the individual characters that's in
the unit and that's what i think really
captivates and elevates this game among
a lot of the other type of games like
this is the way you want to play it if
you don't want to use archers you don't
got to use archers but i don't really
suggest that i'd suggest that you really
get comfortable with everything in this
game and really find out what exactly
works for you and you got to really know
what they're using too you know one
thing i will say about the gameplay in
symphony of war is they do not hold your
hand there's a lot of very very tough
battles in this game especially some
areas in the game where they'll put
undestructable units pretty much they
might as well be indestructible they
know that you are not reasonably able to
take on those units and they will
literally say in the battle look this
dude is too strong for you run don't try
to fight him and i like stuff like that
it gives a little bit more of a you know
an edge when you're playing these games
and find more of a you know a risk and
demand that's on this sure you can try
to go ahead and go up here and get more
of these resources because there are
resources scattered throughout the maps
you know there'd be caves there'd be
houses in general but what's nice is
like they'll put these units on the map
that show up eventually they don't show
up a lot but when they do show up they
give you like look you can go up here
and get these resources but if this dude
catches up to you it's a rat and most of
the time it's not really good to fight
these people you want to just go and run
one thing i don't like about the
gameplay of this is that the main
character dies it's game over i don't
like that with these type of games if
you're playing as an army and as
multiple units i don't really understand
why they would take it to where if one
unit goes down and i understand it's the
main character that the entire game is
over maybe give you enough time to go
over there and revive them i feel like
you know healing and factors in general
should have been improved a little bit
in this game now i'm not saying it was
like horrible or anything but pretty
much how it went is if you had a mage in
your team you can heal one time per turn
outside of battle and pretty much if you
had majors in your unit they would kill
people throughout the actual battles but
if you had a a unit that's in your
actual platoon got really injured and
you had to heal them outside of the
battle you'd have to go to these like
churches throughout the maps that would
either revive someone on your unit or
they would actually replenish the the
hills that that particular unit had so
that that's what i'm pretty much like
the only real big criticism i can get
for and i don't even think it's like a
huge criticism it's just like look next
time if you do any kind of updates or
maybe you make a sequel to this be a
little bit more open to healing in
general because i do feel like it would
get frustrating for a lot of new people
coming into this genre or people that's
not experienced in it that you know
maybe their team isn't lit maybe their
units are a little bit offset and i feel
like there's going to be a lot of
aggravation for people if they don't
really understand the mechanics and i
understand that's not really necessarily
the developer's fault but sometimes you
got to understand that when people go on
there and they you know maybe impulse
buy your game you need to be a little
bit more open to what goes on one thing
i will say that i didn't really like
about this is the lack of voice acting
now there are some voice acting in this
game when you pick a certain you know
character on the battlefield sometimes
they will make
some form of voice now i understand i've
made this criticism in past games before
that i understand that voice acting
isn't cheap but it's just like certain
games like this when you're listening to
the dialogue it's a lot better when you
actually hear a voice and you put
someone's voice to the actual character
and on this it's pretty much like you
just read and i'm not saying that's not
bad but we're in 2022 i don't know how
hard it is to maybe have the developers
read for it and you know when it comes
to that maybe they should have a text
because not everyone should be able to
do that voice acting and i think maybe
bad voice acting is actually worse than
just reading it out loud i get you know
finances budget i feel like the biggest
thing that held this game back was the
budget you know you know voice acting
some animations could have been better
but all that's really nitpicking besides
the the voices i do feel like voice
acting would have took this game to a
completely different level another thing
i thought was actually cool with the
gameplay on there is if you get certain
enemy units down to a certain point you
can actually make them surrender instead
of killing them and what will happen is
if you they surrender to you you can
pretty much sell them back to the army
that you are fighting and i think that's
cool you know it's a little unique way
of actually getting a little bit more
money now i think that maybe you should
have been able to in certain scenarios
actually recruit some of these people
that have surrendered because there was
a lot of times where i wanted to try to
a certain you know build or you know a
certain unit set up and i couldn't do it
because a lot of this the requirements
takes a couple minutes now normally
they're not too bad but there are a
couple of the like the level three
classes and stuff that you know you need
like a strength of 47 and sometimes that
would be like three or four off and you
can use items there's like apples and
you know certain you know consumable
items to increase certain stats on these
units but it was a little annoying
because what i would want to go back and
i'll go all right let me let me get
three people shields put them on the
front let me see how this works with
these certain people on the front
there's a lot of customization i felt
like the customization was halted a
little bit by you know the progression
in general in the game and that's not
really anything bad on the game it's
just i felt like i would have liked to
experiment a little bit more if that was
able to but you know that's pretty much
my review on symphony of war it's like i
said i actually think this is a
phenomenal game and i think it's easily
worth the money that you put into it i
think it's 20 bucks on steam i'm hoping
it comes to consoles i think this game
would actually do really well on switch
playstation and xbox i think this is
definitely a successor of final fantasy
tactics and you know ogres i think if
you love those games even a little bit
like even a little bit this is your game
for you and it's 20 bucks go out here
and support these devs they made a
fantastic game all you have to do is go
look at the steam reviews man it's
overwhelmingly positive you don't see a
game like that you know you go through
there you look at the reviews the
majority of them are positive and i'll
tell you guys right now as being a fan
of those type of ogre tactics and final
fantasy tactics this game is so good it
might be one of the best games i've
played in 2022 i definitely think it's
worth 20 bucks i got about 30 hours in
it so i think that right there just 30
hours for 20 bucks is insane now i did
get a review code so keep that in mind
but i would easily pay 20 bucks for this
game but that's the review of cynthia
the war like i said fantastic story we
were you know could have used a little
bit more visual department that has
decent artwork style but i do feel like
the animations everything could have
been
completely reworked you know obviously
that comes with budget voice acting
could have been there obviously budget
as well story was amazing gameplay was
amazing pretty much this game is an
amazing game and i think you guys should
go out there and get it if you guys
enjoyed this review you can always hit
that like button we make pretty much
reviews every month we actually have
podcasts we have a podcast every sunday
at 1 p.m the iron lures podcast and then
we have the attic show which i host
myself every wednesday at 5 00 p.m i
hope all of you guys had a good day and
until the next review this is lord
addict i'm outta here peace